are still so many aspects of hope
[music]
Run away Chief  I have
n't heard anything from Rokudo, so I can't directly get
involved.
What about Rokudo?
Hey,
that's why I didn't tell you Don't go this time It's
6 degrees This is 6°C It's a matter of pride It's
nothing to do with pride I'm worried Rock video
Tara Rokudo-kun is coming back on this road We are
here
[Music]
What are you doing? Runners waiting for Rokudo-kun
[Music] Because I believe in you  It doesn't
matter if you can't win If you just believe that
Rokudo will do it, then believe in
Rokudo That's right, I believe in 6 degrees too, but it was a little surprising  I'm
waiting for you because I like Rokudo, or
because I love you
[music]